picture two patients sitting in a therapy clinic waiting room. Right. Both of them
actively refuse to go to parties. Both of them have exactly zero friends and both of them spend
24 hours a day, seven days a week entirely alone. Now, from the outside, looking at their behavior,
they are absolutely identical. Right. They look exactly the same to us. Exactly. But to a trained
clinical counselor, one of these people is totally content and the other is in absolute
suffocating agony. Have you ever wondered how therapists and psychiatrists actually know the
difference? It is a remarkable skill set, really. Yeah. How do they look at what seems like a tangled
mess of identical human behaviors and know exactly which, you know, psychological thread to pull? Well,
what we often mistake for intuition in a good therapist is actually a highly structured,
almost architectural system of observation. I mean, they're constantly running complex diagnostic
algorithms in the background of every single conversation. And that hidden architecture is
exactly what we are decoding today. For this deep dive, we've got our hands on a massive stack of
clinical study guides from PassRity Prep. Hosted by Keek. Right. And this material is
essentially the ultimate cheat sheet for clinical counselors preparing for their board exams. Now,
to be clear, our mission today is not to diagnose anyone, you know. We're leaving that to the
professionals. Definitely. What we are doing is extracting the master keys those professionals use
to spot the invisible lines between behaviors that look totally identical to the rest of us.
We want to understand how clinicians navigate literal life or death crises in the room.
Yeah. And when you really lay these clinical guidelines out, they are far more than just
sterile lists of symptoms. They operate like a detailed map of the human condition.
A map that relies on some pretty specific markers, right?
Extremely specific. They sort human suffering by time, by the specific target of the fear,
and most importantly, by the underlying motive driving the behavior.
Let's start with that first marker time. Because reading through these sources,
it honestly blew my mind how much of mental health diagnosis is strictly dictated by the
calendar. To understand the mind, we apparently have to look at the clock.
We do. And we can look at the psychotic spectrum disorders as the perfect example of
this. Clinicians use what we can kind of call a ladder of duration.
Okay. Say someone comes into the clinic presenting with sudden, severe psychotic symptoms. We're
talking active delusions, maybe auditory hallucinations. If those symptoms last less
than one month and the brain circuitry resets. They just fully recover.
Exactly. They fully recover. That is categorized as a brief psychotic disorder. It's an acute
event. What if it keeps going past a month? Well, if those exact same symptoms
persist past the one month mark extending anywhere up to six months, the diagnosis shifts
to schizophrenia form disorder. Wow. Okay.
And if they cross that six month threshold, it officially converts to schizophrenia.
Okay. Let's unpack this. Because the symptoms haven't changed at all.
The person is experiencing the exact same reality on day 29 as they are on day 31.
The clinical presentation is identical. Yeah. But the clock tells the clinician
something fundamental about the underlying neurobiology.
Like what?
Well, a brain can have a short term circuit breaker pop under extreme stress.
That's the brief psychotic disorder. But if that circuit stays blown for over six months,
it indicates that the underlying architecture of the brain
has fundamentally shifted into a chronic long-term condition.
It's like baking.
How do you mean?
Well, the exact same ingredients, flour, sugar, eggs, they become a completely
different cake depending on how long you leave them in the oven.
The time fundamentally changes the chemistry of what you are dealing with.
That is a perfect analogy. And applying that baking analogy to trauma
reveals the exact same logic.
Wailing with trauma.
Yes. When someone experiences a severe life-threatening event,
their brain's alarm system is triggered. If they show severe trauma symptoms,
like hypervigilance or intrusive flashbacks, but it's been less than a month since the event.
It's just acute stress disorder.
Exactly. The brain is actively trying to process a massive shock.
You literally cannot diagnose post-traumatic stress disorder,
PTSD, until that one month mark has passed.
Because the brain needs time to heal.
Right. The clinical assumption is that the brain needs at least a month to naturally
integrate trauma before we declare that the alarm system is permanently stuck in the on position.
The sources also detail how the specific type of stressor changes the diagnosis,
even when the distress is massive. We tend to throw the word trauma around
so loosely in everyday life.
We really do. But clinically, the stressor rule is highly specific.
If the stressor isn't an acute life-threatening event,
let's say it's a devastating divorce or a cross-country move.
Right. Something awful, but not life-threatening.
Exactly. And the person has a severe emotional reaction
that resolves within six months of that stressor ending.
It's classified as an adjustment disorder.
The brain is just struggling to adapt to a new reality.
Yes. But it eventually finds its footing.
We even see this measured approach with grief.
Grief is a totally natural human process.
But if it completely disables an adult past 12 continuous months...
Like they just can't function at all.
Right. It moves into a clinical diagnosis called prolonged grief disorder.
The duration tells the clinician that the natural healing process has essentially stalled.
So time separates the identical symptoms there.
But when we move into the anxiety family, time takes a backseat.
Because, I mean, anxiety just feels like anxiety.
It does. The physiological response is the same.
The racing heart, the sweating, the tight chests.
To separate these, clinicians look for the target.
They have to ask, what is the brain's fear circuitry actually locked onto?
The target names the disorder. It's that simple.
If the fear is pointed at everything, a constant hum of worry across multiple domains
like finances, health, family that's generalized anxiety disorder...
The alarm system just has no specific focus.
Exactly. Now, if the fear is pointed invert at the physiological panic attacks
themselves, meaning the person is absolutely terrified
of having another attack that's panic disorder.
What about social anxiety?
That's when the fear is pointed at social judgment and scrutiny.
And if the crosshairs are locked onto one specific object or situation,
a needle, a dog, flying, it's a specific phobia.
Which makes agoraphobia make so much more sense to me now.
Pop culture tells us agoraphobia is just like a fear of leaving the house.
Oh, that is a massive misconception.
In agoraphobia, the fear isn't pointed at the front door.
It's pointed at the concept of being trapped.
Wow.
It's the profound fear of being in a situation, a crowded theater,
a bus, or a wide open bridge where escape would be difficult or embarrassing.
Or where help would just be unavailable if panic sets in.
And this targeting mechanism, it extends to other clinical families too, doesn't it?
It does.
In OCD, the fear is targeted at an intrusive, unacceptable thought,
which the person tries to neutralize with a ritual.
In PTSD, the fear is targeted at the physiological echoes of a past trauma.
Let's talk about the nuance of schizoaffective disorder quickly,
because this really highlights how precise the timeline and the target have to be.
It's a classic diagnostic separator.
To separate schizoaffective disorder from a severe mood disorder that just happens to
have some psychotic features, clinicians look for a sheer two-week stretch.
Yes.
It comes down to figuring out which engine is driving the car.
In a severe mood disorder that includes psychotic features,
the psychosis only ever appears during this severe depression.
So the mood crash is the engine.
Right.
The mood crash is the engine, and the psychosis is just the exhaust.
But in schizoaffective disorder, there must be a stretch of at least two weeks
where the delusions or hallucinations are present entirely on their own,
while the person's mood is totally stable.
It proves the psychosis has its own independent engine.
It's not just a byproduct of being depressed.
Precisely.
And identifying which engine is running the system
dictates the entire pharmaceutical and therapeutic treatment plan.
Which brings us to the actual stakes of this deep dive,
because while timelines and targeting mechanisms are fascinating thought experiments,
getting the diagnosis right in a clinical setting
isn't just about finding the neatest label.
No, not at all.
We are talking about literal life and death.
The margin for error is razor thin, particularly with mood disorders.
The most dangerous traffic clinician can fall into
is confusing unipolar depression.
Your standard major depressive disorder with bipolar depression.
Because the person walking into the clinic looks exactly the same, right?
They're exhausted.
Their mood is flat-lined.
They can't get out of bed.
Right.
Nobody schedules an emergency therapy appointment
because they feel incredibly energized, grandiose,
and suddenly don't need to sleep.
They come in for the crash.
But the distinction is critical.
Very.
Bipolar I requires just one true manic episode ever
in the person's entire lifespan.
Bipolar II requires hypomania, a liger, less destructive high
paired with major depression.
Wait, hold on.
Let me make sure I'm understanding the mechanics of this.
If someone comes in deeply depressed and a doctor hands them
a standard run-of-the-mill antidepressant like an SSRI
without digging into their history to see if they've ever had a manic high.
Yes.
You're telling me that single prescription
could trigger a manic episode right there?
It can be catastrophic.
Think about the neurobiology for a second.
An antidepressant is designed to increase the availability
of neurotransmitters like serotonin in the brain.
OK.
If you flood a brain that is already structurally prone
to severe overactivation, which is what the bipolar spectrum is
with an activating chemical, you are essentially
pouring gasoline on a smoldering fire.
That is terrifying.
It can instantly trigger severe mania,
complete with impulsivity, loss of reality, and hospitalization.
Bipolar depression requires a mood stabilizer like lithium
or an atypical antipsychotic to anchor the nervous system.
You never lead with an antidepressant alone.
Just a single omitted question in an intake interview
can cause a complete destabilization of a human being.
We see those high stakes echoed in substance withdrawal, too.
I think movies and television have completely
skewed our understanding of what withdrawal actually
does to the body.
Oh, absolutely.
The sources draw a very stark biological contrast
between alcohol use disorder and opioid use disorder.
Opioid withdrawal is genuinely horrific to experience.
Severe muscle aches, intense nausea, insomnia,
absolute misery.
But it's not usually lethal.
Right.
It is rarely life threatening.
Your body feels like it's dying
because opioids suppress pain pathways.
And when you remove them, the nervous system
feels everything at maximum volume.
And the treatment for that is usually medication assisted
treatment, or MAT numbers.
Yes, because of the intense craving and relapse rate.
MAT uses medications like buprenorphine or methadone
that safely occupy the opioid receptors in the brain.
It stops the cravings of withdrawal
without creating the dangerous high.
But the mechanism for alcohol withdrawal
is completely different.
Alcohol withdrawal can actually kill you.
Alcohol is a central nervous system depressant.
When someone drinks heavily over a long period,
their brain compensates by turning up
all its excitatory signals just to keep the lights on.
So if you suddenly remove the alcohol.
The brain is left running in massive overdrive.
This can escalate to seizures in a condition
called delirium tremens, or DTs,
which involve severe confusion, hallucinations,
and cardiovascular collapse.
Wow.
It is a medical emergency that requires supervised papering,
often using benzodiazepines, to slowly step
the brain's overactivity back down to a safe baseline.
It is a wild paradox that the perfectly legal substance
you can buy at any corner store has the withdrawal
syndrome that can literally stop your heart.
It really is.
The clinical guidelines also flagged
a major biological safety rule regarding eating disorders.
Yes, anorexia nervosa carries the highest
mortality rate of any psychiatric disorder.
It is strictly defined by significantly low body weight
alongside a distorted body image
and intense fear of gaining weight.
So the immediate priority is medical.
Always medical stabilization first.
Because the body is in a state of biological starvation,
organs are literally failing.
You contrast that mechanical definition with bulimia,
where the patient is typically at a normal or even higher
weight, but engages in compensatory behaviors
like purging.
Or binge eating disorder, which involves the binges,
but entirely lacks those compensatory behaviors.
Exactly.
And when dealing with cognitive crises, specifically
in older adults, the guidelines are absolute.
You always rule out delirium before you even
think about assuming dementia.
This is a golden rule because one is a reversible emergency
and the other is a progressive decline.
Delirium is acute.
It comes on fast.
The patient's clarity fluctuates wildly throughout the day.
And crucially, it is medically caused.
Like what kind of medical cause?
It could be a severe urinary tract infection,
a bad medication interaction, or severe dehydration.
Dementia, on the other hand, is gradual, steady,
and progressive.
So if a clinician mistakes the rapid onset of delirium
for the natural progression of dementia,
they might miss a totally treatable infection,
and the patient could die from a preventable cause.
Which leads us to how clinicians handle
the most acute crisis of all, assessing suicide risk
in the room.
They don't just ask, are you safe, and leave it at that.
No, they use highly structured assessments, most notably
the Columbia Suicide Severity Rating Scale, the CSSRS.
It forces the clinician to evaluate risk
in a specific escalating order.
Ideation, plan, intent, access to lethal means,
and finally, protective factors.
And the sources are incredibly clear
that one specific practice, which used to be standard,
is completely outdated and actually dangerous.
Yes, no suicide contracts.
Having a client in deep distress sign a piece of paper
promising not to hurt themselves is not evidence-based.
It's just paperwork.
It is essentially cover-your-ass paperwork
that might make the clinician feel less anxious,
but does absolutely nothing to protect the client.
The evidence-based mechanism is collaborative safety planning.
Like building a concrete plan of what
to do when things get bad.
Exactly.
You work with a client to build an actionable list of steps.
Who to call, where to go, what coping skills
to use for when the distress peaks
and their cognitive control slips.
So assuming immediate physical safety is secured,
and we know the patient isn't in a life-threatening medical
crisis, the clinician's job shifts.
It becomes much more subtle, because now they
have to figure out the motive behind a behavior.
Right.
Two things can look absolutely identical on the outside,
but they have entirely different internal engines driving them.
This takes us into the personality disorders,
specifically comparing cluster A,
the odd or eccentric personalities,
with cluster C, the anxious or fearful ones.
The best way to understand the power of motive
is to look at our waiting room example from the very beginning.
Comparing schizoid personality disorder from cluster A
with avoidant personality disorder from cluster C,
both are loners.
They avoid social gatherings, they don't have friends,
they spend all their time alone.
We tend to throw a blanket over both of them
and just call them introverts.
Which completely misses the internal reality.
The motive is the ultimate separator here.
The Cosing with Schizoid Personality Disorder
genuinely lacks the drive for connection.
They just prefer solitude.
They prefer it.
They are detached, emotionally flat,
indifferent to praise or criticism,
and simply do not desire close relationships.
They are fine.
But the avoidant person is in agony.
Yes.
The avoidant person desperately wants connection.
They long for intimacy and friendships,
but they are absolutely terrified
of rejection, criticism, and shame.
So their internal engine is fear.
Exactly.
So they isolate to protect themselves
from the pain of potential judgment.
You can never confuse prefers to be alone
with terrified of being around people.
They use a similar kind of nuance
to untangle borderline personality disorder,
bipolar disorder, and complex trauma, don't they?
Because all three involve massive destructive mood swings.
This is a diagnostic knot
that trips up even seasoned professionals.
To separate them, you look at the tempo and the trigger.
Borderline mood shifts are rapid changing
in minutes or hours,
and they are almost entirely reactive.
Reactive to what?
They are interpersonally triggered
by a perceived rejection,
abandonment, or relationship rupture.
Whereas bipolar.
Bipolar episodes are sustained.
The highs and lows last for days or weeks,
and they aren't necessarily triggered
by an argument with a partner.
They rise and fall on their own
biological episodic rhythm.
And complex trauma.
That emotional dysregulation sits on top
of a chronic long-term trauma history,
often presenting with severe nervous system,
hyperarousal, and dissociation.
Okay, here's where it gets really interesting.
Moving into obsessive behaviors,
there is a fascinating mechanical difference
between obsessive-compulsive disorder,
the anxiety condition,
and obsessive-compulsive personality disorder, OCPD.
Oh, yeah.
Let's say my desk is obsessively organized,
all my pens are perfectly parallel,
I color-code my inbox,
and I get deeply enboyed if someone moves my stapler.
Is that OCD?
No.
And the reason comes down
to two foundational psychological concepts.
Egotysonic versus egosyntonic.
OCD, the anxiety disorder, is egotysonic.
Meaning what, exactly?
It features highly intrusive, unwanted thoughts,
and the person performs rituals
to neutralize the severe anxiety those thoughts cause.
The person hates the thoughts.
They don't wanna be flicking the light switch 20 times.
It causes them immense distress.
And the treatment for that
is exposure and response prevention, or ERP, right?
Where you essentially force the brain
to sit in the anxiety.
Exactly.
In ERP, you expose the person to the trigger, say,
a disorganized desk,
and prevent them from doing the organizing compulsion.
They sit in the fire of their own anxiety
until their brain naturally habituates and learns
that no actual catastrophe is going to happen.
But OCPD is completely different
because OCPD is egosyntonic.
Yes.
The person loves their rigid perfectionism.
They don't have true intrusive obsessions
or compulsions driven by fear.
They just believe their highly controlled,
orderly way of doing things
is the absolute correct way to live,
and everyone else is sloppy and wrong.
So you can't really treat that with ERP.
You can't use ERP on someone with OCPD
because there is no underlying fear to obituate them too.
They think they're right.
The motive completely flips the diagnosis.
The guidelines also explore this internal
versus external motive with deliberate deception,
like faking being sick.
Right.
If someone is intentionally faking an illness
or even physically injuring themselves
just to occupy the sick role,
to get the care, sympathy, and attention
of being a patient,
with no other reward that is fictitious disorder.
The motive is purely internal.
Yes.
But if they are faking a back injury
to get a massive worker's compensation payout
or pretending to be schizophrenic to dodge a criminal trial.
That is malingering.
The deception is driven purely by external gain.
And crucially, malingering isn't even classified
as a mental disorder in the DSM.
It's simply a behavior.
The motive is the master key.
The sources touch on behavioral addictions
and sexuality as well,
and the distress motive applies there too.
I was actually surprised to learn that gambling
is the only recognized behavioral addiction
in the current diagnostic manual.
It sits right next to substance use disorders
because, neurobiologically,
it hijacks the exact same dopamine reward circuitry
in the brain as cocaine or heroin.
Wow.
And because it's a cognitive and behavioral loop,
you treat it with cognitive behavioral therapy.
CBT doesn't use a pill.
It works by identifying the cognitive distortions
like the gambler's fallacy,
the belief that a win is mathematically due
after a losing streak,
and systematically dismantling those faulty thought patterns.
When the sources discuss gender dysphoria
and paraphilic disorders,
they are incredibly careful with how they define
what is and isn't pathological.
The language is precise for a reason.
The critical takeaway is that being transgender
or having an atypical sexual interest
is not a mental disorder.
The identity or the interest itself is not pathology.
Exactly.
The disorder is strictly defined
by the presence of clinically significant distress,
the dysphoria itself, or, in the case of paraphilias,
if the behavior involves harm to non-consenting others.
Distress and harm are the clinical markers.
So understanding all these complex engines,
all these diagnostic rules and master keys,
brings up a massive question.
How do clinicians ethically wield
this kind of analytical power over another human being?
This is the clinician's compass.
The ethical guardrails are rigid.
Client welfare always comes first.
Confidentiality is the absolute default.
And when you are in a gray area,
you consult your clinical supervisor
and you document every single decision.
But confidentiality is an absolute trait.
No.
The most famous exception is the pterosoph
ruling the duty to warn and protect.
If a client presents a specific imminent threat
to an identifiable victim,
the duty to protect public safety
overrides the client's confidentiality.
The therapist must warn the victim
and notify law enforcement.
Then there is mandated reporting for abuse.
Clinicians are legally mandated reporters.
If there is a reasonable suspicion of abuse
or neglect of a protected class,
a child, an elder, or a dependent adult,
they must report it to the state authorities.
Wait, let me stop you there
because the phrase reasonable suspicion
feels incredibly broad.
But don't you need proof?
It seems wild to report someone
and involve the state just based on a suspicion
without investigating first.
You could destroy family over a misunderstanding.
It feels entirely counterintuitive,
especially for a profession
built on gathering information.
But the systemic logic is built entirely around
minimizing risk to the vulnerable.
The clinical guidelines are explicit.
The therapist is a tripwire, not a detective.
A tripwire.
Investigating is the state agency's job.
If a therapist delays reporting to play detective, say,
they decide to interview the parents
to verify a child's story,
they might inadvertently tip off an abuser,
giving them time to coach the child,
destroy evidence, or further harm the victim.
You do not delay protection to gain absolute certainty.
You report the suspicion,
and you let the trained investigators do their job.
That makes total sense
when you frame it as being a tripwire.
You stay in your lane to protect the system's integrity.
And to document all of this,
to prove what they saw in the room,
clinicians use the mental status exam, the MSE.
Because they hold such immense ethical and legal power,
they need a hyper-objective, standardized way
to record their observations.
The MSE is the snapshot of now.
It's not the client's trauma history.
It's a highly structured observation
of how the client looks, sounds, and thinks
in that exact current moment.
The sources highlight two massive clinical distinctions
clinicians have to make during this exam.
The first is mood versus effect.
Think of mood as the climate and effect as the weather.
Mood is what the patient reports feeling.
You quote them in the chart.
The patient states they feel devastated.
And affect is the weather.
Right, so what the clinician objectively observes
on the patient's face, in their vocal tone,
and in their body language.
The crucial diagnostic clue
is when the two are incongruent.
A patient might report feeling completely hopeless
and actively suicidal, but their affect is bright,
they're smiling, and they're laughing at jokes.
That mismatch is a massive red flag.
Exactly, it shows that something more complex is happening.
Climate versus weather.
And the second distinction is thought process
versus thought content.
Thought process is the form.
Content is the material.
Thought process is the shape and flow of their thinking.
Is it logical and linear?
Or is it racing, disorganized,
and jumping wildly from topic to topic?
And thought content.
That's the actual substance of their ideas.
Are they thinking about self-harm?
Do they have a fixed delusion
that the CIA is tracking them?
Gathering all this data ultimately leads a counselor
to a final choice.
Can I effectively treat this person
or do I need to refer them out?
Recognizing the biological limits
of talk therapy is critical.
Talk therapy can rewire cognitive patterns,
but it cannot fix a purely biological crisis.
If a client presents with narcolepsy,
severe obstructive sleep apnea causing cognitive decline,
severe ADHD that requires stimulant medication,
or is going through a dangerous alcohol withdrawal,
the clinician has a duty to refer them
to a medical prescriber or a specialist.
You operate within your scope of practice
and you coordinate care.
It is an incredible balancing act.
We started by looking at this messy,
tangled web of human behavior,
and what we found is that diagnosing the human mind
requires a profound synthesis of skills.
You have to hold strict neurobiological timelines
in one hand, deep human empathy in the other,
and wrap the entire process in rigid ethical boundaries.
And the truly remarkable part
is that clinicians do all of this in real time.
Sitting across from someone in profound distress,
constantly analyzing whether the engine
driving the behavior is fear, chemical imbalance,
or an internal desire for connection.
Which leaves me with a final thought for you to mull over.
We just burped down how the mental status exam
relies entirely on a human being observing the effect
the real time, subtle weather
of another human being in the present moment.
With AI and algorithms rapidly evolving,
constantly trying to track our biometric data,
analyze the micro tremors in our voices
and predict our moods,
could a machine ever truly perform a mental status exam?
Or does spotting the quiet, chilling mismatch
between a heartbreaking story and incongruent smile
require the very human intuition and empathy
we've been talking about today?
Think on that.
Thanks for joining us on this deep dive
and as always, keep feeding your curiosity.